>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Arnold Wiggins: Greetings,
welcome to another Daniel A.P.
Murphy African American Cultural
Association event, special event,
co-sponsored by EEO DP Programs.
Today is a very, very
blessed and special day.
I'm talking off the top of my head
because I think I know Bern
Nadette Stanis AKA Thelma Evans.
[Background noise] We all do,
let's give her a warm welcome.
Let's stand up for Miss
Bern Nadette Stanis.
Today she's going to be
discussing her life and memoire.
>> Bern Nadette Stanis: Thank
you so much, thank you everyone.
I'm overwhelmed, I didn't
know so many people would come
out this morning, but
thank you anyway.
I'm just going to give you a little
brief thing of my life story and ,
you know how I got to
certain points in my life
and some lessons I've
learned along the way
from the parents that I've had.
And you know living, you know
5 years in Good Times and,
those things and how I became
an author and things like that.
Well I was born and
raised in Brooklyn,
in the Brownsville
section of Brooklyn.
I guess you guys know
where that is right?
It's the projects.
So there were 5 of us.
I'm the eldest of 5 and my mom
and dad in a 2 bedroom apartment.
So you can imagine.
But my father's thing was
education, with education
and determination you can do
anything in the world you want.
So he spent all, he and mommy,
spent their money on educating us,
putting us through
parochial schools,
all kind of private
schools, dance classes,
you know music classes,
and things like that.
And you know I can remember going to
school, it was like 10 blocks away
from you know where we lived.
And it was called Our Lady of
Loreto and on the way there,
I learned a lot of things, about
the neighborhood, about life.
And what we would see all the
time would be the heroin addicts,
you know, going, when
I was going to school,
now you know what heroin addicts do.
And the hands on the
heroin addicts were
like three times the
size that they should be.
And what we would do is, as
children we would make bets as to
which one would fall, you know which
one would hit the ground first.
And as you know, they never fall.
>> That's right.
>> Bern Nadette Stanis:
It was amazing.
They would go all the
way down to the ground
and never fall [laughter].
We just thought that was amazing.
So I'm just saying that this was
the kind of environment I came from.
And what my father
always said was this,
what's around you does
not have to be in you.
And he made sure that
we understood that.
He was a very wonderful daddy,
he was a very disciplinarian,
he was very strong in that way at
education and being disciplined.
Mother, on the other
hand, a southern gal,
you know from Jeanerette,
Louisiana, she was very,
very soft spoken but
very, very stern.
And she meant what she said.
Some of the lessons that I learned
from them, I'll just jump ahead.
My grandmother put me in dance
class at the age of 5 years old
and told my mother
to keep me in dance.
And I think she did
that because she knew
that if you were busy doing
something positive there's less
opportunity to get into
something negative.
So I stayed in dance class all
of my life to become a dancer.
Now, I remember a lesson, one of the
lessons that I learned, from my mom.
I was about in the tenth grade,
no I was about in the fifth
grade and I was 10 years old.
And there were two girls in my
class that I wanted to be a part
of their clique, that's when
I learned about cliques.
And [laughter] I wanted to
be a part of them so badly
because they were beautiful,
they were smart,
they were everything I wanted to be.
I was the type of student
that, I was very creative
but I was like a B, C student.
So they didn't want
me in their clique.
I figured this out from the
first grade to the fifth grade.
Now what I figured out was this,
if I can become an A student
like they were, then I would
automatically you know,
be part of their clique.
So I studied and I
became an A student.
This one test was very,
very hard and I got an A
and I was so excited, so happy.
So in recess here I am, you know
they're playing double Dutch,
you all know about
double Dutch [laughter].
And I am walking over to them
and say okay, can I play?
And they looked at me like they
always looked at me and said no.
No you can't play.
Well that was a lesson
that, that I'll never forget
because it really, really hurt me.
I did not understand that, I didn't
understand why I was not accepted,
why they didn't like me.
So again I go home that day crying,
you know, asking my mommy, why,
why don't they accept me mommy, why?
And she says, I don't know why
Bern Nadette, I really don't.
She said but listen, you are
very creative, you can dance,
you can draw, you can
paint, you can write.
I'm like ugh, that's not
what a child wants to hear
in a situation like that [laughter].
So I moped around and I moped
around that whole evening.
And I, I'm very religious and
I believe in God very strongly
and I think that is
because my mom did too.
And sometimes I believe that,
we get messages from God
to help us guide our children.
And I know that this had to have
happened for my mother, this day.
So she came in the living room
and she sat right next to me
and she said, Bern Nadette,
one day the whole world is
going to know your name.
Yet she didn't tell me that Thelma
would be the first name [laughter]
instead of Bern Nadette, she didn't
tell me that part [laughter].
So, so I said okay mom,
whatever, but that,
but you know the clique thing
faded away and I continued on
and to do what I, you know do.
Another lesson was this.
I learned a lot about my
mother's character from this.
There was a beauty
pageant, and I wanted to be
in it but I was too young.
The pageant, Miss Black America
was from 18 on and I was about 14.
And my mother said, you know there
should be a pageant for teenagers,
they want to get in
these things too.
So of course, being the mother
that she was, she went to the head
of the pageant you know thing.
And Mr. Hal Jackson
was the leader then.
And she went over to him and she
said, Mr. Jackson, my daughter is 14
and I know a lot of teenagers
want to get into pageants
so why don't you have
a teenage pageant?
The very next year he
had that teenage pageant.
So, well what I learned
from that was
that when there is no
way you can make a way,
if there's no door you can
make a door to walk through.
And my mother made that door for me.
Now, I am going to the beauty
pageant every Sunday with my mother
and her other four children,
so, all the way to Manhattan,
so it takes about, about
an hour to get there.
We did this for about 6 weeks
and the seventh week was
the pageant, that Sunday.
And I got up that morning and I
looked in the mirror, and I said,
I am not going to that
pageant [laughter].
Not me, I meant that to, so I moped
around, I looked kind of strange.
And my mother says you
better start getting dressed,
it's about that time.
I said mom, I'm going
to tell you something,
I'm not going to do
it, I'm not going.
You know she laughed right?
She said you better
get dressed, stop that.
I'm like no, I really
mean it, I'm not, I'm not.
And she said yes you are.
So you know I don't bugger
too much but, I acted out.
I moved like molasses I was
hoping that I would move so slow
that the pageant would be over
when we get there, but it wasn't.
Finally, we're on the subway,
and I would not sit next to her
because I'm very angry
at her by this point.
And, you know if you
do have a little bit
of asthma you can make
asthma [laughter].
So I sat up there and I mustered
up an asthma attack, oh yes I did,
I did it I went [laughter].
Until I couldn't catch my breath.
So by the time we got off
the subway, I, here I am.
Mom [laughter].
I can't [heavy breathing] you know
we know our children [laughter].
My mother looked across the
street at the drug store
and she said you see that
drug store over there?
We're going to go over there, get
that Primatene mist [laughter].
Now you know Primatene mist you
can get, back in those days,
and you're going to take it and
you're going to get on that stage
and do what you're supposed
to do you know all that.
So I just said well boy
it's over now [laughter].
I got to get well and I got to
get up on that stage and I did.
And it was that Sunday,
that a man came to my mom
and said you know we're looking
for a teenager for a show,
and it looks like your
daughter could fit right in.
And so we're going to give you this
card and we would like you to go
to CVS tomorrow and meet Norman
Lear and you know audition.
So my mom took me the next day
to CVS and we go up to the room
and we open the door, and
there are thousands of girls.
I'm like wow.
So anyway, you know I knew not
to act up because you know,
the day before wasn't
so good for me.
So anyway, [laughter] I sat there
and I started thinking to myself,
and I said, I thought about
something my dad always said.
What's for you, no
one can take from you
and I kept saying that
and saying that.
So when they called me in,
I see Norman sitting there,
you know behind the desk,
Norman Lear the producer of All
in The Family, Jefferson's
and all these different shows.
And of course I saw Jimmie
Walker standing there
with that dumb hat on
his head [laughter].
So, so they give me a script
to read and the script looks
like it's somebody who wrote
it, what they thought a teenager
in the ghetto should say,
rather than what she says.
So I say to Norman Lear, Mr. Leer
is it okay if I can improvise?
Now because I had been
taking acting classes
for awhile [laughter] I
knew how to improvise.
So he looked at me and he
said, yes, go ahead improvise.
You know he's got hundreds
of girls auditioning.
So anyway I get up there and I
say to JJ, I said something like,
look JJ you better help me clean
this house before mommy gets here.
I mean you better wash those dishes,
or you better take the garbage
out, something [laughter].
So he says well I'm not washing
dishes and the garbage isn't full,
so I'm not doing anything.
So I, we were going back
and forth, back and forth,
so I hit him, I did, I hit him.
I hit my brothers.
So I hit him on the arm and he goes,
you know that long face he makes
that, and so we go back and forth
and Norman starting laughing.
So I, after that audition I didn't
hear anything back from them
for like two months so after two
months you just say well okay
it's over.
And after two months
I got that call,
my mother got that
call, that I was Thelma.
[ Applause ]
Thank you, but what I
learned from that was this,
that morning that I got up and I
looked in that mirror, and I said,
I'm not going, it was
only because of fear.
It was, I was afraid that I
was not going to be picked
or that I'm not pretty
enough or I'm not enough.
And, fear got a hold of me and
it worked it, it worked it.
And what it taught me was this,
don't let fear stop you from walking
into your destiny, because truly
Good Times became my destiny.
Although I always wanted to
be a doctor, a psychologist,
a psychiatrist, only because
I love the way the mind is
and why people do the
things they do.
And especially got more
interested in it as I,
you know grew up, and
started dating.
Now, [laughter] I'll get
back to that [laughter].
Now on Good Times, it was very,
very interesting because I was
like the newcomer, I didn't
know anything about anything,
I was just so excited to be
around them, and you know them,
meaning the stars you know Esther
Rolle, John Amos, Ralph Carter,
and Jimmie Walker and Ja'net Dubois.
They all were so acclaimed,
even at that time.
And I learned a lot of lessons and
you know, I have a lot of lessons
in my books to that I talk a
lot about what I've learned.
But, it was one day I was at Esther
Rolle's house, now Esther Rolle
and I became very, very close,
because I wouldn't let
her go home by herself.
I was always there, I would say
mom, can I go home with you?
She said, why?
What do you want from, what?
I said I just want to
become, I loved her,
I just wanted to be around her.
So she just accepted
me as a daughter
because I wasn't going
anywhere [laughter].
So here we are rehearsing our
little lines, now remember,
in the beginning, the first
6 months, all Thelma had
to do was say hi mom,
hi dad, shut up JJ,
she was in the bathroom right.
So this went on for like 6
months and I was getting bored.
I really was.
So I told, I said mom, you
know I'm getting kind of bored,
you know I think I could do more
lines, I think I can do more.
I want to do more [laughter].
And she goes, oh you
know, oh really.
Yeah. She says, so you
want to do more lines?
Yes. She says, she waited a long
while, and then she said to me,
okay, let me handle this.
Oh I was so happy she said that,
because I wouldn't know
how to handle that.
So, the Friday that
we had the reading,
because we always have readings
for the next script on Friday.
Again, my lines were good morning,
hi mom, hi dad, and bathroom
and hey shut up JJ, that's it.
So at the end of the line reading,
Esther said to the producers,
because in the line reading
we had the producers,
the writers, everybody's there.
And she said, I want
to ask a question,
and they said of course Esther,
you know what is it,
you know she's the star.
So she, you know does
what she wants.
So she says, I want
to ask something,
are you ashamed of my daughter?
And they said no, why?
We're not ashamed of her.
Well then why are you hiding her?
They said well we're not
trying to hide her or anything.
So she said well I want my
daughter to have more lines,
I want my daughter to have a voice.
My baby son has a voice,
my older son has a voice,
and I want my daughter
to have a voice.
And so from that moment on I
had a voice, Thelma had a voice.
She had an opinion.
So I give Esther Rolle
all the credit
for giving the first black
female teenager on television,
her voice and her opinion.
[ Applause ]
I've got to have a
little water here, yeah.
Now while on the show,
some things happened.
While on the show, I lost
my voice in the third year.
Mmm hmm, what happened was I
would get up in the morning
and I would sound like me but by
3, or 4 or 5 o'clock I started
to sound like, more like a man.
And then in the evening
I could hardly talk
and my voice started to hurt.
So I went to a specialist to
find out what was going on.
And he said that you have
nodules on your vocal cords.
And they have to be removed.
Removed, so I'm saying okay
so what does that entail.
So they say well, once we remove
them, it's two ways that it can go.
You could lose your voice, or
you can get your voice back,
but you will have to be
quiet for like about 6 weeks.
>> Wow, wow [laughter].
>> Bern Nadette Stanis: Quiet, me?
I'm always on the phone,
I'm always talking,
I can't, be quiet for 6 weeks.
So I told the producers what
the doctor said and everything,
and so they suggested that after
the operation what I should do is,
study the lines but don't speak,
just speak on Thursdays, tape day.
And the doctor said
that would be fine
and it ended up being very fine.
So that's exactly what I did but in
that process, you know I realized,
you know looking back, that,
you know since I do believe
in God very strongly I know
that he moves in certain ways.
And for me I did not understand why
my voice was silenced for 6 weeks,
but in that process,
this is what happened.
I decided that I was going
to write everybody stuff,
you know how you'd get a pad, a pen
and you just write down everything
and show it to them, and then
they can talk back to you.
Well back then they didn't have
texts and spell check and all
that [laughter], so
that got ridiculous.
So I just decided,
okay I'll shut up then.
But in the process, God gave
me something very precious,
he gave me poetry, and
he gave me stories,
and he gave me the ability to write.
I developed it right there and
then and I never stopped writing,
and writing poetry, and
beautiful things like that.
Years later, like 30 years later, I
kind of realized why that happened.
My mom by this time was
diagnosed with Alzheimer's, and,
and before that, like
I said I always studied
about relationships
and things like that.
So I knew a lot about
relationships by this time.
I used to ask my mother
before she got Alzheimer's,
I used to say when I was
younger, hey mom tell me,
you know what should I do about
this guy and what should I do
and how should I handle this
and how should I handle that.
And she says, well Bern Nadette
you know, I've only been married
to one man, I don't know
how these things work.
So what you need to do is
read everything you can learn,
so that's why I did that.
But, [laughter] okay by this time
I realized that I was working
on a book and the book
came about like this.
And it's called Situations
101, Relationships,
The Good, The Bad, and The Ugly.
And, at first I was just the
girl that everybody would come
to to ask questions
about relationships,
like I was the girlfriend
that you would call.
Guys, girls, are going to call
me, they would ask me something
and I would tell them and it worked.
So, they always did that,
except I had one girlfriend,
who would call me all the time,
but this time she calls me
like at 3 in the morning.
And she keeps calling me,
until I answer the phone.
So when I answer the phone, she
said he's not home, he's not home.
I'm like who's not home?
The same guy she was talking
to me about for 3 years,
the same guy, he's not home.
Well I said how do you
know he's not home,
maybe he's asleep,
it's 3 in the morning.
No, he's not home, why?
Because I kept calling him and
he wouldn't answer the phone.
So, how many times did you call him?
About, I don't know
15, 20, I don't know.
15, 20 times, this is a
problem and I can't solve it.
So what I said to her was this,
I'm going to write down some things
for you so that you can put it in,
on your refrigerator in the middle
of the night if you can't
sleep and you're worried
about him not being home, maybe if
you read it it will calm you down,
until at least about 6 [laughter].
You know and if that doesn't
work, then do like I do,
open the refrigerator and
eat something [laughter].
So she just whatever and so anyway
I started writing these things down
and that's how I ended up writing
this book called Situations 101,
Relationships, The Good,
The Bad, and The Ugly.
I did 101 different situations
that I had heard and answers
that I had given them,
and I realized
that you know people really
needed that, it was interesting.
But in that process I would always
call my mom and we would talk
about the relationship stuff and
some of the things in the book,
The Good, The Bad, and The Ugly,
and I'm saying mom you think
I should put that in the book.
And she says well if it's real put
it in there, it may help somebody.
Right after that book was
done, my brother called me
and said you know it's time
for you to come get mommy
because mommy's not doing so well.
When I went to see her, I realized
that she wasn't doing so well,
she spoke well, she hid it
well, but her hair wasn't right.
And you don't put polka
dots and stripes together.
So I said you know
something is really wrong,
I said okay mommy you're coming
home with me and we're going to,
you know see what's
going on, you know.
I never made her feel
funny about it.
So we went to the doctor and they
diagnosed her with Alzheimer's.
And when the doctor did that
he looked at me and he said,
your mother has something that
we call, you know Alzheimer's,
and I'm going to give you some
medication and you give it to her,
and it should, you know
help her out a little.
I'm like what?
Help her out a little about what?
What is that?
Well it's, and he looked
at me like this.
And I got very angry with him
because I thought that was rude,
you know, but not knowing
what he knew.
So I said okay, okay we'll give
her the medicine but you know what,
mommy, we're going
to fix this thing.
We have come through everything,
we're going to fix this thing
and we'll give you
a lot of vitamins,
a lot of this, a lot of that.
And I was fighting for it,
and I was on the internet
and I was asking questions,
and I said no, no,
there's got to be an answer to
this thing, this is not real.
They said there is no
answer, there is no cure.
I know there is a cure,
this can't be happening.
I fought for 4 or 5 years
with there must be a cure.
Until I start seeing
what it really was doing.
The decline, you know, and the
mourning that a caregiver goes
through while watching
your loved one decline.
My mother was so sweet, stayed
sweet, and was wonderful.
She didn't have a problem with it,
I don't think she really
realized how sick she was
or what this thing was.
And, but I realized it, and
that's why I wrote the book
about The Last Night, a Caregiver's
Journey Through Transition
and Beyond, because I
realized that I took
on the weight of this disease.
My mother would eat and forget
that she was, had eaten.
And she would always
invite me to eat with her,
so I kept eating with her.
Now she would get skinny and
I would get fat [laughter].
But I didn't even realize that
I was gaining so much weight.
I mean I remember going to
the store, to buy some clothes
because you know my clothes
weren't really fitting anymore.
And so I tried on this size,
I'm not going to tell you
what size it is [laughter].
And I realized, I'm like oh come
on now these people, come on,
they're making the
clothes too small.
[ Laughter ]
But then I really realized,
yeah I guess I had gained
some weight, you know.
But that didn't matter to
me, my mother was going,
my mother was dying, and I knew it
and I'm still fighting with her.
And everything, she asked me or
said I said yes, I agree, I agree,
I agree, everything's fine.
And then one day we were
watching Good Times [laughter].
One of her favorites, and she was
watching JJ and me and Thelma fight
and everything, and she and
I were just sitting alone.
And she looked about
me and she said,
you know that's a cute
little old girl.
[ Laughter ]
And I said yeah, yeah ma she is.
But at the same time it was like a
knife in my heart that was twisted.
Because this monster of the mind
had taken away, from my mother,
the very thing that
had changed our lives.
And I realized then this thing
is very serious, very serious.
And so I said, if and
when that day does come,
I'm going to form a foundation
for my mother called
Remembering The Good Times
and Alzheimer's Foundation
in her honor.
[ Applause ]
But anyway, that day did come.
And if we have a few more
minutes I'll explain it but.
>> Sure.
>> Bern Nadette Stanis We do?
>> Yes.
>> Bern Nadette Stanis: Okay.
The reason why I call it
the last night is because,
the day before the last night,
I spent with my mother,
I was a nervous wreck.
I felt something it's as if God
was whispering in my ear, you know.
And everything was
going wrong, everything.
By this time, mother had stopped
speaking, no she was speaking
but she was not swallowing,
she was not.
So she was in the hospital with
the tubes down at her throat
and all this other stuff and
they're telling that she's going
to get a splint in the
arm and everything,
my mom does not want all that.
So anyway, the day
before, I was panicking
and I told the doctors please you
know, my mother doesn't look well,
you know, is there more
medicine you can give her,
is there anything else?
You know more oxygen, something.
And they're saying your
mother is very ill.
I said I know she's very ill,
that's why I'm asking you
to give her more medicine, help her.
Give her some antibiotics,
give her something.
They said okay, we're going to do
that, because they realized I'm one
of those that you know,
didn't see the light.
So that evening I went by there, I
went by to see mommy and I said mom,
it's about 10 o'clock now.
I said mom, I'm going to go
to the Alzheimer's Association
tomorrow morning and I'm going
to speak about you because you know,
I have to speak about, you know,
Alzheimer's that morning,
the next morning.
So I said but I'll be here
about 11 o'clock okay?
She said fine, and she
nodded, you know she heard me.
And so, it was just myself and
my daughter who was about 16
at the time, my baby daughter.
And she and I went home and
she lay on one couch and I lay
on the other couch, my husband
was in New York at the time,
and my older daughter
was at her apartment.
So about 2:30 in the morning,
the phone rang, and I froze
and my baby said ma, answer
the phone, it's the hospital,
answer the phone, you know.
And I let it, I didn't,
I let it go to voicemail.
She said mommy, you
better call them back.
So I listened to my
voicemail, and they said come
in because your mother's
vitals are failing.
And you never know what you're
going to do at that moment,
when you've had your parent all of
your life, and that moment is here.
So what I did was, I really froze,
now I know that it was coming but,
at that moment I froze,
and I couldn't move.
And she's saying mommy, come on,
I'm standing there walking around,
talking to myself and
saying to myself this is it,
this can't be it, this is it.
And I could not get it
together, and so thank God
for that 16 year-old girl, she gave
me my pants, she said ma come on,
here are your pants,
come on, you know.
You know here's your shirt, put
it on you know, here's your hair,
put it on[laughter],
glad she said that.
[ Laughter ]
So I got myself together [laughter]
and she said here are your
keys mommy, I can't drive
yet so you have to drive.
So I'm driving, I'm driving, and
I'm praying, I'm asking God to,
you know what am I going to see.
I mean what's she going
to look like?
What am I going to say?
What am I going to do?
And then when, by the time I got
to the hospital my older daughter
was there, my baby daughter was
on this side, my older one's on
this side and I'm in the middle
and we getting ready to
walk through that door.
And just before I walk to that door
it was as if God just put something
in my head and he said,
this is going to happen,
but don't make it bad for her.
I knew exactly what he
meant, because my mother
and I are very, very close.
And if I had just done
something like,
you know I knew would hurt her.
So I walked in and I said mommy,
I'm here, I'm here with you
and I don't care how long this thing
takes, a day, a minute, an hour,
a year, I'm not moving, I'm
going to lay down right here,
right here beside you ma.
And I asked the nurse, I said could
you please just move her over,
just a little bit so
I could lay on her.
Oh we can't do that [laughter].
I said well maybe you
can't, but I can [laughter].
So they moved her over
and I lay down by mommy,
I put my leg on her leg,
and I put my arm on her arm.
And I was going to put my head
on her chest but you know she had
that respirator thing going.
And my mind said, if you do that
she won't be able to breathe, so,
it's funny what your
mind says you know?
And so I got a pillow, they
gave me a pillow and I lay down,
and I was just lying
there, and it was very,
very peaceful in that room.
Mommy was very, very peaceful,
it was as if she was okay,
she was okay with everything.
And, I laid down there and
I saw a clock on the wall
and the clock said,
2:30, and everything was
so quiet, and I fell asleep.
I fell asleep in my dying
mother's arms, and when I woke
up it was 4:30, and I panicked.
I'm like, and I'm looking
over to see what,
and mommy is still looking
around, still peaceful,
still looking around,
and I said thank you God.
I didn't miss it, I
didn't miss my mother.
And then the pastor came
in, the priest came in
and gave her her rights,
she's Catholic.
And, my older daughter came in the
room and my baby daughter came back
in the room because they were
in the other room sleeping.
And so, she said mommy,
her eyes don't look right.
And I knew and I said well, okay,
okay show her the picture of Jesus.
So she showed her the picture
of Jesus, and she said mommy,
mmm she's not looking at that.
I don't know, I said well
show her the picture of Mary,
because I know she loves Mary.
So she showed the picture of Mary
and she said, she said mommy,
her eyes don't look
right, she's not looking.
She's not looking, she's looking
like through the paper or something.
And I went around to the side where
mommy was and I looked in her eyes
and she was looking
around, and looking around.
And it was as if she was
looking in amazement,
and I said Dior [phonetic] I think
she's looking at the real thing.
And at that moment, I could see
the eyes going a little darker,
a little brown, and little like red
blood shots were coming and I was
like I can't believe I
am looking in the eyes
of death, I can't believe this.
I couldn't believe it.
And I knew someone said start
talking, and I said ma, ma,
I love you mommy, I love you, I
love you, I love you, I love you,
I love you, I love you, I love you.
I love you, I love you, I love
you, I love you, I love you.
And I said I know you love me
too, I said but well had fun,
we had fun ma, and
we had a good time.
But it's not over yet,
then she left.
Then they escorted me out because
they had code blue taking her back
and they asked me do
we bring her back?
Yes, bring my mother back,
yes, so they brought her back
and by this time, my daughter had
called my brother who is a pastor.
And they said to me, we got
your mother back I said,
you got her back, okay.
And he told me Bern,
Bern, you know you got
to let her go, you
got to let her go.
It hurts to do that, I said
oh no, no it doesn't hurt.
So then she said, and then, then
I said to my brother I said Kyle,
I said something very
weird happened.
I said when I was laying there
with mommy, I said I fell asleep
in her arms for 2 hours, I said
how could I have done that?
He said because it wasn't for you.
It was for her.
And she knew that if I could
fall asleep, I would be okay,
that was God telling
her, Bern will be okay,
because she always worried about me.
You know the others would be
fine she said but me [laughter].
You know so, the nurse came back
in and said, you know, I said no,
no, it's okay let her go.
And so they said you
can see her if you want,
come back in you can
see her if you want.
And I'm so scary, I'm like no, I
said to my baby daughter who's 16,
she said I'll go in mommy.
I'll look at her, if she looks
okay I'll let you know, if not,
you don't have to come in.
So she went into the room and she
looked at her, she said mommy,
she looks like she's sleeping.
So I went in the room, and I looked
around at her and we all know
that the hearing is the last to go.
So for about a half an hour
you know they can, hear.
So I saw a little tear like in her
eye, and her mouth was a little open
from the trach being in there.
And said mommy, I'm going
to close your mouth,
I'm going to close your eye,
and I'm going to wash your face
for the last time, and I did that.
I put her music on, it was
the most peaceful night,
it was incredibly peaceful.
I understood it, it did
not feel like a death,
it felt she just transitioned.
Because I always felt her
with me, it was incredible.
I told her she was beautiful,
I let her speak to my brother,
I let her speak to
one of my friends,
I mean I let them speak
to her [laughter].
And, I put her music on, and then
of course you know how pastors are,
they're like that, in a minute
they were there to take my mom.
I'm like wait a minute, they got the
black bag you know, wait a minute.
I said no, I can't see this.
So my baby, daughter again, said
mommy I'll stay with her, you go.
So I left and she stayed
with her all the way
down until they put
her in the truck.
So that was an incredible,
incredible night, and I had to write
about that night, and I had
to write about the story
and the reason why is
because when I said it's not
over yet, it isn't over yet.
The fight to fight against this
Alzheimer's disease is not over yet.
And it was given to me to fight
because I feel that I have
to take this face that my mother
gave me, to put to the face
of Alzheimer's and fight so that
her death wouldn't be in vain.
And that's how I felt about that.
[ Applause ]
>> Let's give her another
round of applause.
[ Applause ]
We would just like to say that our
Thelma is still beautiful [laughter]
and fine [laughter].
At this time we'll have a reading
from her book by Iris Taylor.
>> Iris Taylor: This is a passage
from her book entitled,
the Last Night.
>> Iris Taylor: Oooh.
This is the before.
Mom had made it to
her 80th birthday,
even though she had
been battling illness
that threatened to take her life.
She was in critical condition with a
temporary tracheal tube in her mouth
and down her throat, but that
didn't stop us for celebrating,
not only her 80 years on
this earth, but my appearance
on the television show
The View, that morning.
From the day my book Situations 101,
Relationships, The Good, The Bad,
and The Ugly came out, she told me
that she wanted to
see me on the show.
Her wish came true on her birthday,
Friday, September 30th, 2011,
my appearance was like a
birthday present to her.
There I was, on TV with Jimmie, JJ
Walker, walking about Good Times
and my relationship book.
I bought mommy a dozen balloons with
one huge balloon that said, mom,
I love you, so happy 80th birthday.
I held mom's hand and
we played music,
I know she enjoyed me being there
because when I said, mom I'm here,
she showed me excitement
and opened her eyes.
I was happy and felt a sense
of accomplishment but fear
and anguish had that
grip on my heart.
But I never let my mom know the
pain that I was enduring, the pain
and the fear that became my
constant companion, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you, Iris.
At this time we will have
questions come from you all.
If anybody would have a question
you like for Bern Nadette,
would you stand up and
stat your question.
Anybody? Okay.
>> How you doing?
>> Bern Nadette Stanis: Fine.
>> Out of your 3 books it
seems like this is the most,
it's very personal to you.
>> Bern Nadette Stanis:
Which one, this?
>> The one, yes, this one here.
>> Bern Nadette Stanis:
That one there.
>> Yeah, that's very personal.
>> Bern Nadette Stanis: Yeah.
>> Is there a book that you
consider your favorite out of the 3
or is it just the fact that
each one has their own identity?
I know my favorite's the
one just for Men [laughter].
>> Bern Nadette Stanis:
The poetry one [laughter].
You can order it on my website.
>> Yeah.
>> Bern Nadette Stanis:
ThelmaGoodtimes.com.
>> Yeah.
>> Bern Nadette Stanis: But that was
a nice book, that book of poetry,
I really enjoyed writing that one.
This one became very dear to
me because this was the one
that my mom kind of
helped me with, you know.
And I would tell her about the
relationships and everything,
and you know, stuff,
we would go through.
The other one, called Finances,
Situations 101, Finances, The Good,
The Bad, and The Ugly you can
also get that on my website,
was the second book that I wrote,
coming out of this one because,
touring this book, realized
that in relationships,
a lot of relationships
break up because of money,
that's one of the biggest things.
Because we don't even
have a relationship
with our own money, first of all.
So when we're sharing it
with someone else, you know,
get pretty rough you
know [laughter].
So.
>> You don't want to share it.
>> Bern Nadette Stanis: Yeah,
you know because some people want
to share, some people
don't want to share.
You know some people are
spenders, some people are, savers.
You know you marry a
spender, you're a saver,
you know tug of war [laughter].
You know things like that, so we
had fun writing the second book,
but the third book,
that one right there,
I had to show who my parents were.
I had to show what they did
in the world because they did
so much, they sacrificed so much.
My mother sacrificed so much,
and to never be known for that
or to know that, you know you did
so much and no one knows your name,
you know, things like that.
So I said I want to
honor her for that.
I'm going to honor my dad for that.
And you know where I came from you
know, and that all, you don't have
to always, you know look at
a person because they come
from a certain part of the
world and down them or,
you know disrespect them,
or anything like that.
Because we all, you know, come from
different places and we all can grow
with love, understanding,
we all can make it.
>> Bern Nadette, we've watched your
show over the years, and Good Times
and the scenes of a lot of
the show were every intense.
One of my favorite episodes
was with Debbie Allen
when she played the heroin addict
who was about marry JJ [laughter].
Do you have a favorite
Good Times episode
that you enjoyed working with?
And a lot of the characters are
very well known actors today,
so everybody got a star.
>> Bern Nadette Stanis: Yes,
they did, thank you for that.
Well I have a few.
I particularly like
the African prince
because that was my show [laughter].
And they gave me a
two parter [laughter].
And then also the wedding.
>> Oh yeah.
>> Bern Nadette Stanis: Yeah,
and then one of my, yep,
and one of my very favorite
ones, was the one that,
when Penny was smoking and she
put that, yeah, Janet Jackson.
And she put the cigarette
underneath the couch
and nobody knew who
did that [laughter].
And I got a chance to play like 3
or 4 different characters
that Thelma is.
You know like that, I became
a witch, JJ's witch, remember?
You know, and stuff like
that, so that was a lot
of fun, I enjoyed that one, yes.
>> Yes, this past Saturday I didn't
even know you played [inaudible]
in Love Boat.
>> Bern Nadette Stanis: Yeah.
>> I didn't know you played
and I saw you [laughter]
and it [inaudible].
>> Bern Nadette Stanis:
Clifton Davis, uh huh,
yeah, yeah, yup, yeah, yeah.
>> I enjoyed that episode.
>> Bern Nadette Stanis: Oh,
thank you very much [laughter].
I had just played, yes.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Bern Nadette Stanis: Well we
had that last month, in February,
it only lasted for a month and they
told us to bid high, so we did.
We said we're trying to raise a
million, and that didn't happen.
So, but that is because
Kick Starter,
Kick Starter wasn't quite
the platform for Good Times.
Because not a lot of
people knew about it,
and then they couldn't find
us when they did get there.
So, that didn't happen but
we have private investors,
so the movie still might happen.
[ Applause ]
>> Next question, mmm hmm.
Go ahead.
>> Okay. I'm just curious, I
look at a lot of the reruns
and I often wonder whatever
happened to those Ernie Barnes,
the artwork on that show,
the Ernie Barnes originals.
[Inaudible] ever give
them to you guys?
>> Bern Nadette Stanis: Oh
no [laughter] no, no, no.
No, no Ernie was on scene and
those belonged to Ernie Barnes.
>> Right.
>> Bern Nadette Stanis: And
now they belong to his wife
because he passed away
a few years ago.
>> Yeah.
>> Bern Nadette Stanis: Mmm hmm.
>> Okay.
>> Bern Nadette Stanis:
I wish he had [laughter].
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a
presentation of the Library
of Congress, visit us at loc.gov.